so we are going to
be talking about making data science
notebooks collaborative
uh what i really mean is we are going to
discuss real-time collaborations so this
is something you might be used to
from uh for example google docs or figma
or similar tools where you can just you
know uh send a link to all your friends
or your colleague even share it on
hacker news whatever
all those people can come in and see the
same content at the same time well
eventually same content but we are going
to get
into that uh tiny bit deeper so yeah um
this is it but i'm gonna start with like
a
short obligatory slide about me so right
now i am cto at bibnode
um i'm not sure if many of you have
heard about us so far
if not i hope this is going to change
really soon
we are making a collaborative data
science platform so
really what we are enabling people to do
is go
and work on the data science projects
together
without any barriers uh it's pounding
environment super quickly everything is
managed everything's in cloud
so maybe doing something like uh google
docs did for microsoft word uh
like uh 10 years ago apart from that
before i
um started working deep note i did some
artificial intelligence research
at imperial college london so you can
see like a couple of
pictures uh here at the bottom so i was
really working on this robotic arm that
was uh
trying to take a piece of cloth from
from the ground and then
lift it and hang it on the hanger this
was all trained simulation and then it
was transferred to an actual rear robot
and this was using the brain personal
learning uh neural networks of that
so if you are by any chance interested
in robotics or reinforcement learning i
will be super glad to talk about it
cool um with this out of the way i can
really uh introduce the talk
so uh in the first couple minutes we are
going to be talking about jupiter
notebook internals
i believe most of you guys have heard
about jupiter notebooks but
maybe you did not yet have a look about
what's going on
under the hood so i'm just going to
uncover like a couple of basic building
blocks
um then i'm gonna talk about the
real-time collaboration
uh i'm gonna motivate the use case for
it and then i'm actually
going to explain how it works uh so all
the technicalities so this is with the
middle of the talk
um then you know like taking your data
science environment
from um your laptop into the cloud
brings a lot of security issues so i'm
just going to touch on those and tell
you like how we are solving some
some of them if you're interested and at
the very end if the time allows i'm just
gonna give like
a quick quick demo of deep note as it is
running
right now okay um so starting out
um jupiter notebook uh i'm not sure how
to do this i was hoping to have like a
quick show of hands about how many
people are familiar with jupiter
notebooks are using them
i i thought there was like this thing in
zoom where you can just raise hand or
something
is this the thing or
uh there is yes we are raising the hands
you can see i see uh see a
finger i see uh people raising hands
i i believe that i can just take it as a
like i've got a normal sample of the
whole population of data scientists in
my toe
so i assume that 80 of you guys have
raised hands because
um that's like the sample of people in
data scientist population around the
world that are
currently using jupiter notebooks so you
could say this is really like a big
prevalent tool
in a sense uh okay
apart from the jupiter notebook is
really moving from uh
like the domain of data science into
also different fields you know biology
and even you know like devops
engineering um i
remember a story from a guy at netflix
who told me that every single scheduled
job
in netflix and so like cron jobs or the
data pipelines all these
are jupiter notebooks and the idea is
that the
jupiter notebook is a familiar interface
pretty much
eighty percent of the engineers have
already made the jupiter notebooks
more or less uh so when people join
netflix they already know how jupiter
normal books looks like they're familiar
with it
so it's only natural that if they come
in and see the user interface
for a scheduled job to be jupiter
notebook they can immediately do work
for example there was this engineering
manager that hadn't written code for
years because he was now like an
important manager
and he got paged because like somebody
didn't answer to a page so the page
escalated and escalated
up to this guy and this guy not knowing
well forgetting how to write code just
said you know like
what the hell i'm just going to try so
he clicked on the on the link he saw a
jupiter notebook
that he saw the documentation because
there is like this markdown data
he saw the code he saw the error message
he saw everything in one place
he was able to identify the mistake the
the error and quickly fix
it this wouldn't be possible if like the
logs were in one place if the code was
at another place documentation
some sort of gt3 pro or whatever so
really jupyter notebook is
omnipotent omnipresent and it's like a
really great tool
cool moving on uh i'm wondering if any
of you guys have already
looked inside the jupiter notebook like
what it actually is what's the file on
the disk
so it really is just a json file
if you are not familiar json is like a
very uh popular format for communication
that is human readable
so pretty much all of current internet
is running on json files being exchanged
back and forth
as you can see this is for example
jupyter notebook
and if any of you guys have any ideas
what these jupyter notebooks might be
might be doing
it's not the easiest way to read it uh
but to give you a hint the source code
of the cell is over here
so it's literally just like hard coded
string saying print hello world
uh as we are in the python group i i'm
hoping that this is going to be familiar
to you guys
this is literally just outputs hello
world
and over here what we can see is the
actual output so we can see that hello
world was printed to
a standard output so this is really just
the
single cell inside the notebook
otherwise there is some metadata saying
that this is like a python notebook
uh there is a notebook format um this is
not particularly important but there are
like five versions of jupiter notebook
uh files that exists pretty much all
notebooks today are version four
uh we have seen and upload like a couple
of jupiter notebooks version 3 but
nobody really cares about those anymore
cool so uh now when we know what the
jupiter notebook actually is on the disk
it's just a json file i can dive into
the actual architecture of the jupyter
notebook world
itself i'm not really good at making
making those well
diagrams so i just stole this from the
jupiter
documentation you can also find it there
but really what this means is that you
are the user you are just sitting here
there is a browser in front of you
and you are just seeing you know like
the javascript and hdr
html that was transferred to you and you
are seeing all the cells and all the
code
this communicates with the so-called
notebook server notebook server is a
component that is actually taking those
notebooks
and saving them to the to the disk so
it has an idea that there is like you
know 10 cells in your notebook the cells
contain this code this is the order of
the cells
and it compares this to the to the disk
it can serve you
uh the data to the browser but it's not
doing anything with the code itself
it's not executing anything for that
we've got a kernel component
so kernel component is the one that is
um
really running your code and this is
language specific you you probably
know there is like a python kernel the
most common one is ipython but there are
some others there is python and
well there is big branch but you might
have used other tools if you use r there
is
kernels for r there is kernel for bash
kernel for sql like there is a big bunch
of those
well and the kernel is actually not
necessary to do the editing of the
notebooks
you can have like a standalone notebook
server without any kernel
and you can be just you know like
editing your notebook saving it every
now and then
and everything works just just nice
because but you are not executing the
code
so now if we zoom in on the kernel
component over here for a moment
um what we can see is i'm just going to
move this again a tiny bit
what we can see is that there is uh
really this is a simple component there
is like an execution request coming in
this is just the code so for example
print hello world
uh what is coming out is an execution
reply
so this is just saying that this got
executed and there is a side effect so
for example the
the stream saying hello world uh as we
as we had from from an example
so uh the kernel has no idea about the
fact that there is like a notebook
that has cells or anything you are
literally giving it like the
data from a cell and then it gets
executed and you get the reply but it
doesn't know that it was a cell it could
have been just like you know
like a string that you wrote all right
so
um this is really all the moving blocks
that i wanted to talk about the jupiter
internals because
this is going to show us how to uh what
we need to actually build like real time
collaboration components
cool so well now let's talk a bit about
uh
real-time collaboration um i'm gonna
start by telling you something about why
real time collaboration actually matters
what's so important about it
so uh what we are looking at here is
some sort of like
usual company uh there is some legal
department some managers marketing
but here at the center it's us you know
the the data science team the
people using python or sql or whatever
to to
do something big data and it's a it's a
couple of people you know
and those people might want to
collaborate for a lot of different
reasons for example
this guy might want to get a code review
from this guy so he can send
a notebook and uh get some sort of
comments they can even jump on the call
and look at the
same notebook they can edit it together
but apart from this there is a lot of
other use cases
for example this guy can go on a holiday
and the others
other people want to look at the his
environment if his environment is
offline inside his computer there is
like no way they can access it
otherwise maybe this guy starts running
a module and also goes home
for uh or goes to a theater or whatever
right
if the model is running in classic
jupiter there is no way to check
progress
the other people can access it so the
collaboration helps in all those use
cases
uh maybe one final thing is uh maybe
some of you people are familiar with
using heat
uh is that right uh git
for uh version control so um
it's a like a tool that allows you to
version control your code
and in some situations you might end up
with two branches
that you are merging and this produces
some sort of mesh conflicts potentially
so if you are looking at the same
code in real time and you can share it
there is no concept of a merge conflict
because you are always looking at the
same
same state same same ground rule
however like outside of the data science
teams the benefits of real-time
cooperation are also pretty big
so for example if you are communicating
marketing you are probably you know like
taking screenshots of your graphs or of
your outputs and then sending them
slides
and but now if you have like a
collaborative environment in cloud you
can just send them a link and tell them
you know guys uh here is all the graphs
we can we can just edit it together they
can have a look
so really it just makes the access to
data like
really prevalent inside the world
company which is amazing
all right cool now go to the codec
technology part so i'm just going to
move this
somewhere again hopefully this is not
going to be
hiding anything okay cool so
let's talk about real-time collaborative
editing um
let's say that we've got two users okay
uh there is alice and there is bob
we are not going to talk about notebooks
at this point because it's uh too
difficult so they're just going to be
starting with a simple string
so there is they both have string abcd
now
uh this is similar to google docs you
know just like simple takes that you
already think and we are just going to
find out how to do it
so let's say that bob wants to do this
operation
he wants to delete the character b which
is at position one
so delete one alice wants to do another
operation
which is inserting x at index uh
three so quite straightforward bob is
going to end up with acd
alice is going to end up with a b c x d
so
0 1 2 exit position 3 and b
super simple but now there is a problem
we need to make sure that they are real
real-time collaborating
so they need to be able to share the
data about their edits
um the naive way what could we could do
is just send this operation to alice
send this operation to bob
and let them apply them so this is what
could happen
i'm just going to take the string acd
insert character x at position three and
i'm just going to end up with this
string
at the same time alice is going to take
the character
the abc xd delete
um character at position one and she's
gonna end up with ac xd
but what you can probably see is acdx
is not the same acx d those two
characters are switched so we've got the
divergent state and everything is
blown up everything is horrible
so instead uh what we can do is
introduce another component
so let's say let's have a central server
that is also managing these
these transactions okay um what we can
do
now is the same scenario alice inserting
x bob
deleting b okay now
they both tell the server listen server
i just want to
delete character at position one i want
to insert x
and arbitrarily even if it's happening
roughly at the same time
the server says um that this packet the
right first
so i'm exit going execute this first
then this packet the right second so i'm
going to execute this second
and now the server can tell bob and
alice that this is the resulting
situation however there is a problem uh
this can take quite a lot of time so uh
imagine that you are editing a document
you can write a character
and then wait 100 milliseconds until it
appears because the server needs to
acknowledge your operation
well i'm guessing you would be very
unhappy you know that's just gonna take
forever
so this is also not an option
so now um there is another way to do
this
and this way is called operational
transformations
uh okay so well i'm just gonna uh the
situation now is uh similar as we have
had before
so again bob and alice uh same string
and now wait wait
now what happens is that they are going
to apply the operation delete insert
the server is again again there and the
first operation is
easy it's uh it just arrived it's a it's
applied and now their state is acd
okay so the server has its own internal
ground state and this is acd this is
the basis operation transformations but
now there is the second operation
and uh because we have applied the
operation first
we need to transform the second
operation
so we can see that the insert x at
position three
became insert x at position two this is
the
transformation that just changed the
index of insertion
because the delete operation was applied
before it obviously makes sense you know
like
uh i wanted to insert the character
after c
but something got deleted you know so i
just need to change the offset
so this is probably what alice wanted to
do alice wanted to write an x after c
it's not like ali wanted to write it in
a specific index
so the meaning of the operation is
preserved
and all the operations were transformed
so now the server has the correct state
server knows that the state of the
document is ac
xd if that makes sense
now moving on we've got a
new situation so now when ac xd
is uh the server is the state we need to
tell bob and alice about this change
it's simple to tell bob right because
we can just tell bob that after you
applied your delete which already
happened
you can insert x at position two which
is already in transform operation
bobs and ends up with ac xd
okay um now we go the
alice so alice has
now already inserted uh
as you can as you can see over here i i
just went one slide back alice has
already inserted her x
so now the problem is that we need to
roll back the operation that alice did
so the first thing we do is we roll back
the operation
then we apply the deletion and then we
apply the new insertion
so this is similar to how how git works
and this is also the basis operational
transformations
so the first operation is rolled back
because the server didn't
accept it and the server tells you what
are the other operations
and now what you can see is we've got
the same state
both with both alis and bob has the same
state which is amazing
and they can type without waiting for
the server to
acknowledge information but sometimes if
server says no
they need to roll back and apply the
changes again
cool now let's introduce yet another guy
so this is chris sorry if this is
getting uh
too complex any any any any questions so
far
or
okay uh i take silence as a
understanding everything so i'm just
gonna move on
so there is chris uh chris was online
before
he he was at the same state uh with abcd
uh but now what happened is that chris
lost connection to the server
for example he was traveling from
bratislava to bruno there is no internet
all the time in the train so he lost
connection and now
chris needs to come back online after
this those those two changes good
applied
so what happens is that the version of
document of chris's document is v0
you can imagine version as like every
increasing number each time an operation
is applied
so we applied two operations version
here is two but chris is version zero
so chris knows that the server
has version two i've got version zero so
i need to ask server for your data
so chris goes to the server and says
please give me operations one and two
server
just gives chris the operations and
chris applies those operations increases
back
online uh and has all the all the rights
right data at the state if chris was
typing when he was offline
the same operation would happen as we
explained it bob and alice
so everything chris typed is going to
get rolled back
and then all the operations from the
server will be applied
and then all chris's operations are
going to be applied on top of whatever
came from the server
so this is how it works if you are
familiar with git
this is very similar to what happens
with p3 basis
if not i hope this was uh this was kind
of interesting
this is how google docs are working and
this is also how deep mob is working
so operation transformations is the way
but now we only talk about this about
strings
so just like simple simple textual
strings
what happens with notebooks so as i
mentioned understand
notebooks are just big json files okay
so
it's a json object very or similar to
dictionary in python uh it's just like
keys and values that are not mapped
together
luckily uh the operation transformations
have implementation
for objects or for dictionaries so it's
pretty much saying you know
for example uh this is an operational
transformations
that inserts an object on this path
inside
inside json it's not too important to
understand this um
the point is that you can simply apply
the same algorithm
i was talking about here to notebooks
but uh
just like the simple simple extensions
so
what is going to happen with other
architecture over here
the only thing we need to do right now
is
replace the notebook server with like a
special notebook server that is capable
of handling operation transformations
so right now if this is an operation
transformation component
that can do the collaborative
deconflicting and all that
what can we what we can do is um
just connect another user over here to
the same operation transformations
component
and then they ask for something to be
executed
the state here gets sent to the kernel
you get the results and otherwise you
are just typing
using the string transformations i have
explained so it's actually fairly simple
we replace this one component in the
architecture and everything
just works nicely the only only problem
is that you also need to replace the
browser so it can
communicate with the operation
transformations component so this code
would need to change as well
nice um any questions so far
on um operation transformations or just
like collaboration on strings
i know this being quite demandful so
i'll be happy to also answer the
questions later on if
anyone is interested cool
um sorry um there's just there's a one
question on slido regarding
uh what if bob once added the same
object as
you so regarding the merge conflict i
think you explained it but if you could
just quickly go through that
okay okay um so it really depends on the
situation
so for example um if you are um
changing text this is this is fairly
simple but if we are working
on notebooks so for example one of us
can be
changing a specific cell so maybe adding
some code and the other person can
delete this cell
this is obviously an operation that is
impossible to recover so this is some
sort of a possible conflict
the operation transformations algorithm
itself can resolve the simple conflicts
so for example if there is a deletion
like no edits make sense on that object
so they are they are just deleted
and otherwise in the worst possible case
when uh there is a conflict that is not
recoverable
what we can do is just tell the user
like sorry this edit
was conflicted uh you can just you know
the edit was thrown away and you need to
start working again
um this is usually not such a big
problem because if you are connected we
are thinking the data really quickly
so within a couple of seconds the state
is consistent
um otherwise if you are just offline for
like two hours and then connect back
sometimes uh you might lose some part of
the edits
um that's that's just how it is so the
recommended way of using the operating
transformations
is to be to be more or less online
okay i hope that answers the question
and i'm moving on
cool uh okay so we've got another thing
so
apart from notebooks um many data
science workflows require you to use
terminals
to install stuff to configure stuff or
to really just do whatever so
we were thinking about whether we want
to make terminals collaborative as well
this is super controversial but we have
decided like yeah everything is
cooperative
so uh there is also a nice use case for
it you know
uh if you are teaching your student to
use for example git we talk a lot about
git and it's a difficult topic
you can just like fire up terminal and
you can type and people
on all connected people just see the
same same results
and this is interesting because we don't
need any sort of operation
transformations or anything difficult
for this
because in terminals when you type
something
um it's not there is a chance that the
character is not going to appear on
screen
for example if you are using beam as
your editor you can navigate using jnk
to throw out the file so if you write j
no j appears on screen but your cursor
is going to move down
um so really what we need to do
is uh wait for the server until it
acknowledges the message
and then uh it actually writes the
results results back
so whatever is the ordering of the
messages is just going to be followed by
the
by the server and that's pretty much it
and
really this slide is interesting for you
guys because if you are using ssh
or secure shell to connect to any sort
of like a remote
meshing or something in the cloud
whatever
you might be used to this because if you
have
bad internet low latency sorry high
latency
then typing in ssh is very painful so
what you can use instead is a
tool called wash has a
thing called speculative local echo so
what it does
is that if it sees that when you are
typing
the characters are appearing on the
screen it's not going to wait for the
server round trip but it's going to let
the characters appear immediately
and if it sees that like you are typing
characters are not appearing but
something weird is happening for example
to view navigation
then mosh is just going to stop doing it
that instant just wait for the server
for the acknowledgement
so using um experience of using secure
shell
or ssh is much much worse than using
wash if you are if you have solve
internet
so this is just something that is cool
and we are thinking about
implementing speculative local echo in
deep node in the coming coming weeks and
months so this is no bit there but it's
going to be there and it's going to make
the
experience much nicer cool moving on to
security uh it's going to be very quick
um but as you can imagine
taking your local
data science environment to the cloud
might have like a lot of security
implications
so first thing we need to think about is
the browser security
and the more biggest issue there is
cross-site scripting or
xss so what can happen is
this by the way the most common security
vulnerability it surpassed
buffer overflows as the most biggest
security vulnerability couple years ago
so what can happen is that in a jupiter
notebook
you can have a client side javascript
for example you have like some fancy
um interactive component for example
from plotly or volume or
similar libraries you can have a
component of this you know there's like
some sort of pidgey
some that you are using to control
your execution or something so this is
client-side javascript
uh but there can be a bad guy so for
example if i wanted to
uh steal uh jan's data what they can do
is uh
i can create a notebook which has a
client-side javascript saying take jan's
cookie and send it to me
if youngs opens this notebook the cookie
is just gonna get sent
and jan is pawned and i i can still
steal his identity
so there are two ways to mitigate this
one is
sanitizing the outputs so this would
mean that we can just strip all the
javascript for all from all the
notebooks
and say that no javascript gets executed
but this is bad experience
the other option is iframes so this is
uh what we are currently doing
so all client-side javascript is
embedded in an iframe so it's really
like a browser topic but what's
happening is that we send books the
javascript so we cannot steal cookies
and because
like the attackers cannot really do
anything with the local storage of the
browser
so it's really a sandboxing topic uh
also jupiter is doing this maybe you
have seen uh the concept of drastic
notebook
so uh you can tell jupiter that you
trust this notebook and at that moment
jupiter actually executes the javascript
if you don't trust the notebook jupiter
just strips away the javascript so like
some
interactive thingies are not working so
this is why the
thrust is there okay
another thing is that like in deep node
what you can do is uh
take run your computer science
environment or data science environment
the cloud
what we do is behind the scenes we
create a container that is actually
running all this
um you might have heard about containers
from you know devops people it's like
the
topics of docker and kubernetes and so
on uh one thing i want you to take away
from this talk
is that containers actually do not
contain that the name is wrong
uh because they are not really a
security boundary if you are uh
if you don't know what you are doing and
you let arbitrary person inside the
container
it's not that hard to actually break out
of the container and
be like a root user on your actual
machine so
there is a lot of ways to prevent these
what we are doing is stripping
uh operation system capabilities
creating a lot of network
restrictions and also um sandboxing the
wall container inside the application
space uh this is all
bit of advanced topics so please
remember containers do not contain
because this is the
interesting stuff and if you
have any specific questions about these
i will be happy to answer them after the
talk
okay now with the time
seems like i put like two minutes for
the demo so i'm just gonna gonna quickly
run
run two through this um so this is deep
note
uh you can take even more if you want no
no don't don't
rush so much okay um so
sure i'm just gonna i'm just gonna roll
with it for for a moment
um this is um so this is deep note
this is a bit of like maybe familiar id
interface you can see there is like a
file system over here and this is like
the main project view where you will go
to cell
i'm just going to populate it with
something so there's like the sample
project
so we have something to quickly talk
about
um this is similar to jupiter in deep
node you can execute your
your cells your code this is all running
in the cloud
um inside inside your own container and
the cool thing is that you can actually
share it with people as i mentioned
right so you can share it by link
or you can invite like any
your colleagues or something for example
my colleague is actually in the talk so
i'm gonna invite him here
so he can uh collaborate with me on the
on the notebook itself
um i'm hoping he's around um
we'll see if he connects okay in the
meanwhile uh what you can also do is um
for example visualize data in uh
in csv so instead of like the classic
jupiter output that you can see over
here we are adding like a lot of
uh nice histograms and just like making
the data exploration tasks much easier
inside deep node
uh there is also like actual
visualizations where you can plot the
variables and so on
if you need a stronger machine stronger
hardware there is like a
options if you connect there is more
options you can get oh it seems like
jakub just connected let's see what he's
up to
it doesn't seem like he's in a notebook
yet
sorry i logged in with different email
so i can only
okay um
anyway um while yakub sorts out his
email situation
uh if you want to bring your own
container
uh there is like a specific custom
docker file so you can install whatever
libraries you need
you can connect like a bunch of
different integrations you know the
classic postgres
[ __ ] s3 whatever you need you can use
git
i i talk a bit about terminals so as i
mentioned you can just like spam
terminals
even become super user so install
whatever you want whatever we need
maybe maybe let's come back to see if
yakubi is around
it seems like finally someone is in the
notebook
but still uh still not the aqua
apparently
so in the meanwhile i can show you that
if yakub is not coming we can just leave
him leaving the comment
uh i don't know
we can just speed
and oh i got a
question in check
oh what component do we do we use for
web terminal client uh coming back to
the terminal
uh this is
this is extern i'm not sure what's uh
so yeah as i mentioned you can see that
this is a tiny bit slow
uh just because this is still going back
and forth to the server
uh but with the speculative local echo
it should be should be much faster
any other component is x10
okay
i guess um this uh although
it seems like there is somebody over
here um
just to simplify this tiny bit
i can just change it change this link
and open it in
another tab i guess
oh there is there is all the people now
over here i can just type and you can
see you know like the classic
collaborative cursors
this is this is the other me uh
collaborating at the same time
cool awesome um so
coming back to the presentation
i think my internet died because i can't
even change the slide
okay anyway uh the last slide was just
thank you for your attention so i don't
think i need it
uh cool that was pretty much it uh any
questions right now or should we wait
for the
for for the break address thank you very
much uh thanks for the talk
luckily your internet connection may be
down but you're still
heard so that's fine okay
uh there are actually four questions on
slido
so i can read them so first of them
is would you recommend deep note for
teaching
yes i actually would recommend ibn for
teaching um we actually had like a lot
of um
already running teaching engagements um
the university of cambridge was running
uh one course in deep note
in uh in spring so the professor was
super super
um happy about it because now like the
all teaching is going on remotely
so there was like a couple of groups and
like the professor could
literally just like come into the
group's project and help them with
things
same with teaching assistants so the so
cambridge
people had like a really amazing
experience and now we've got
another teaching engagement at harvard
university and
from the big names and then we got like
a bunch of teaching
engagements at like other universities
around the world a lot of them in india
for example
so people are using people for teaching
already it's going quite well
okay thank you uh another question what
is it
what is the difference between deep note
and google collab
so okay sure so um google collab is not
actually collaborative
um that's like a funny funny thing um
right now if you if you want to
collaborate on google on
google co-op you need to actually save
the
action notebook to drive and then like
open it elsewhere so the real-time
collaboration component was there for a
while
it's not currently there it's because
the underlying library code good
discontinued
at google otherwise you can't do
a lot of other things in google google
co-op you know so there is like
no first class integration with
like different different other tools
there is
you can do for example to doing in
terminals and also
uh google collab and just like randomly
interrupts your computation we don't do
that
um so uh right now if you if you run
your computer for a while it's just
gonna it's just gonna be there when you
come back it's not like google cloud
that just randomly interrupts you
after 30 minutes or 120 minutes and also
we are building
we are planning to build a massive bunch
of other features you know starting with
those visualizations that i mentioned
there is a lot of other other other
things that i'm just going to be um
at the different edits at different
stages after google cloud
so you can see that there is pretty much
feature parity we are even better in
some things and
well google club has been around for a
while we've been around for just
shorter while i guess
okay another questions are there any
javascript incompatibilities between
classical jupiter notebook and
deep note such as there are between
jupiter notebook and jupiter lap
yes uh so right now we are supporting
all the classic ipanb format if you want
to come to the node you can just
um bring your own python and
b but with respect to javascript
incompatibilities yes there is a couple
couple of issues
so for example um
right now we've got some trouble running
some visualization libraries for example
volume
just because of the security concerns we
did not want to implement the trust
i mentioned because uh it's just
confusing for people like a lot of
people don't understand the concept of
cross-site scripting don't understand
the concept of trust and what it means
so we just want to avoid this and we are
using different measures as i mentioned
those iframes
and this is introducing a lot of
incompatibilities
but we think that security is more
important than features right now and we
are instead just trying to fix
volume in iframes as opposed to
implementing trust which was confusing
thank you uh there are still three
questions so probably not more now
we will stop after this three we should
stop uh
is it possible to run deep node server
on the local server um
so right now it is not because the node
is still
uh like a work in progress product and
it would slow us down terribly because
then like you
you would we would need to do like a
proper uh versioning issues with bug
fixes releases and so on
so within our roadmap want to make some
sort of a
local deep note but it's not coming in
the next next couple of months or
like we are not sure when it's coming
yet
uh okay another question
uh you talk about operational
transformations uh have you considered
crdts
uh which means conflict-free replicated
data type
yes uh like it seems like crdts are the
winner
these days but we could like a very
specific use case i'm
gonna go back to the slides really
quickly
just to this slide over here so we need
this guy we need a notebook server
and the reason is that like there needs
to be some ground stool to the
descending data to the kernel and
sending the data back
um crdts are peer-to-peer
so like you can collaborate between
multiple users
but uh this guy would just be another
user and it would create all the
base conditions and incompatibilities so
it's really important for us to have
uh ground truth and see our operation
transformations have
this sort of um thing like the ground
through this on the server
there is a lot of other things that made
us do this decision and i can talk to
you about it later very interesting
okay then the ultimate question
is there some good way of storing
notebooks in gate
okay good question i mean that only
could code could be stored and
there would be conflict uh on conflict
on select execution
okay um yes
uh i guess i can i can answer it so
there is no super good way uh the
recommended
idea is that if you are committing a
notebook you should be creating all the
outputs
because really what's creating all the
all the mess is the
is the output it's not the code so if
you clear all the outputs the other
people clone it
they can they can just rerun it that's
like the the easy way and that's
probably what we should be doing
uh otherwise i don't have a better
transfer right now but yeah
we are right now starting to build
versioning in deep nodes so hopefully
this problem is not going to be there if
you start using copper to our product